when omicron was identified in a south
african lab the nation responded with
something of a shrug
adults went to work children went to
school
although they still have to wear a mask
at tutalarae high
if you raise your voice
they see that you're serious
like this one heymon what's your mask
put it on propane
go
okay so there are some challenges yeah
very
but there's no appetite here for
distance learning
covert has kept students away for over a
year
it's satisfying you know it's a it's
exciting to see these young people
coming in
you know the way they do
it's great it's just a great thing
i look alright
staff at this hospital in pretoria were
the first to encounter omicron and they
may be the first to see it go the
current wave is practically over here
are there
seven patients but there's something
else on dr fareed abdullah's mind
he thinks covid will target those with
battered immune systems like people with
untreated hiv
and the consequences could be severe in
south africa we obviously want to make
sure that more and more people with hiv
get onto treatment so they don't fall
into that category but you know my
humble opinion that's where the epidemic
is shifting now to that small group of
people who are immune compromised
scientists have discovered that people
who aren't taking their medication for
hiv
risk long and severe forms of covid and
when covid is left unchecked in the body
it can mutate into other strains
and it means that
quite a major reorganization of the
health services firstly these people are
difficult to find
you know how do you make the diagnosis
in a lot of these people
but you know that's where modern
medicine has to take us
rapidly we have to make a plan to go out
to look for patients
is a health worker in clerkstorp and a
bit of a detective looking for people
who've stopped taking hiv treatments
called antiretrovirals
and there's lots of work to do sky news
understands 3.6 million in south africa
have untreated hiv
sylvia fanvick stopped taking
antiretrovirals two years ago making her
susceptible to illness ulimon defaulted
and when she picked up kovid well she
couldn't get rid of it i was so sick
that i couldn't even do nothing nothing
at all my mom was
my mom was always there for me she was
the one who was
watching me
giving me food and all those things i
couldn't do nothing
sylvia had covered for three agonizing
months but when she restarted her hiv
treatment her body fought it off why did
you stop taking it
i was i was
uh
fully speaking i was
entertaining too much
truly speaking i was entertaining too
much i didn't take care of my health
that's not something this clinician in
clerkstorp wants to hear when we're
talking about hiv
we tell our patients
you must absolutely not miss even a
single dose of your arvs and there's a
new worry now
if the immuno compromised catch covered
it could lead to a dangerous new variant
they're just sitting with covid sort of
brewing inside of them so it does itself
just keep changing
within this person's body and definitely
it results in a situation where
potentially
it becomes like omicron which becomes a
variant of concern
as omicron fades a new priority looms in
south africa
people with weakened immune systems need
care and vaccines but there are millions
here who have neither
tandy is a sex worker from zimbabwe who
struggles to get antiretrovirals
and she can't get a covert vaccine when
i went to hebrew hospital they couldn't
attend me because i didn't have my
passport was expired
what a mess
yeah
yeah
it's difficult eh it's difficult for us
especially foreigners now it's very very
difficult
an open door is the only answer to all
those in need of treatment
in the age of covid our collective
health depends on it john sparks sky
news in johannesburg